خساره غير متوقعه للاخضر السعودي تقسيخ
خارج بطوله كاس العالم المقامه في قطر بعد
اداء ومستوى قوي قدمه في اولى مباراتين
كما تشاهدون الجمهور السعودي الذي قدم من
مختلف انحاء المملكه
لمؤازره الاخضر السعودي في
هذه البطوله خرج مغادرا من ملعب لوسيل
الذي ملئه عن بكره ابيه الان نلتقي باحد
الجمهور السعودي المشجعين السعوديين
الخارجين من الملعب بشكل عام ما رايك بعد
خساره المنتخب وخروجه من المونديال بمستوى
الاخضر بشكل عام في البطوله والله الحمد
لله على كل حال اولا واخيرا همم المنتخب
ادى في المباراه الاولى اداء جدا مشرف
واداء قوي جدا وهذا الاداء القوي
في تاثير السلبي على المباريتين الثاني
على بولندا وعلى المكسيك اليوم شروط ذهني
من اللاعبين صراحه اختيارات المدرب كانت
شويه همم
ما هي صحيحه تنسيق اللاعبين في التشكيله
منتخب بولندا منتخب يعني مستوى اقل من
عادي مستوى اقل يعني متوسط للاقل من عادي
لكن المكسيك سرعات عندهم سرعات لعيبه
سريعه فاحنا ضيعناها من مباراه بولندا من
المفروض البلنتي لو سجلنا كان خلصت المرنه
الدور 16
سلمان الفرج قائد الفريق الروح راحت
وما كان في اداء في
خصوص البودره
المنتخب شرفنا الصراحه الامانه شرفنا لكن
الاصابات والحظ طبعا الاصابات لها دور
كبير
الاصابه سلمان اصابه همم ياسر الشهراني
هذه يعني
البدلاء ما قصر ولكن لهم تاثير تاثير كبير
الرياضه والله ابطالنا نقول لهم شكرا لكم
ما قصرتوا الجمهور ايضا الوفي اللي حضر من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه واشجع جميع
العرب نتيجه اللي حققها امام الارجنتين
هذه البطوله نعتبرها احنا حافز باذن الله
للبطولات القادمه خروجا مر للمنتخب
السعودي ومغادره كبيره للجمهور السعودي
الذي ملئ الدوحه خلال الايام الماضيه
باعداد غفيره لمؤازره المنتخب السعودي بعد
تفاؤل كبير اصابهم بعد نتيجه تاريخيه ضد
الارجنتين لكنهم يعذونا انخفاض اداء
المنتخب السعودي وخسارتين متتاليتين من
بولندا والمكسيك للاصابات القويه التي
اطاحت في المنتخب عبد المحسن الحربي